all right Quinn
Quinn now where'd you grow up where are
you from where am I from I'm from
Lakeland Florida Polk County 863.
tell me about your family uh my family
um well both my parents were divorced my
mother was Miss Cape Coral in 1985.
um just normal middle class family you
know my mom cleaned houses when I was a
kid
and um
they told us we could be whatever we
wanted to be
I wanted to be an actor a musician yada
yada nothing practical
um and um I had a lot of success I did
like news when I was a kid I I said the
Pledge of Allegiance in front of the
whole school I won uh poetry Awards went
to a performing arts high school for
technical theater
stage management
um and I went to college and I dropped
out of college and started using drugs
um but I'm still trying to pursue those
dreams and you know try to not have
regrets later
how old are you I'm 29 29.
how did you
how did your career kind of take it that
turn when you started using drugs
um
well I was in a lot of relationships
that were like
uh
not they just kind of took me away from
focusing on my goals and my dreams
I've always wanted to fall in love ever
since I was a little kid I always
dreamed about falling in love and
you know what that looked like and how
that felt
so I always chase boys and then I chase
girls for a while too and
um it's kind of just taking me away and
wasted a lot of time in my life from
really pursuing my dreams I've always
had a job I've always been the one
working and providing you know
um
you know you're down here but never down
here but now you're down here no well
I'm over here yeah I'm I where do you
stay now I I stay in a tent right now
um last year I was staying downtown
and a artist it's it was like an artist
house it was like a hostel for artists
and I got away with not paying for maybe
five months
um
but that's another story
um I've never been anywhere La is the
biggest city I've ever lived in and
every something new all happens every
single day that just makes me feel alive
you know but it was your drug no what's
that what drug are you using now I'm
using fentanyl but I'll use anything
how do you support yourself
I
I rely on a kindness of strangers and
EBT
California has a lot of good benefits
for you know people come over here to be
homeless you know from States all over
so that's not what I did that's not why
I came over here but
um it seems to be working out all right
um
you know I don't want to be homeless my
whole life but I've always kind of been
a gypsy Nomad kind of person you know
other things about this lifestyle that
that are that you like
yeah I feel I feel free I mean to do
what I want and I don't
I don't want to have to I've had a job
my whole entire life always works always
always work and just until the past two
years I haven't had a job I got fired
for the first time in my life and it
blew my ego completely
and I haven't had a job since I've just
been doing my own thing and living how I
want and having as much sex as I want
doing as many drugs as I want and uh it
comes with the consequences of course
um but you know since moving to La I've
learned a lot about myself and I've
changed a lot
like a lot
in what ways
um
I've I've like discovered my dark side I
think
I've discovered like
pretty much
you know I I don't know I don't know how
I don't know how to really answer that
like
because it's still like in the process
I'm still in transition like I'm still
I feel like I've been in transition for
a really long time
so I feel like I've just been kind of
waiting for
it to come to fruition you know
did you still talk with your family yeah
they're really supportive and missed me
um
I have two daughters
and um they're in open adoptions and uh
I I don't I don't I'm not connected with
them like this I I chose to like have
them grow up with families that could
take care of them
um
and
you know
recently the the father of both my
daughters passed away
um from a heart attack and uh
that's been really hard on me
um
but I'm hoping that I can use my pain
and my trauma to you know make better
art
and uh I'm hoping I can get through this
you know
sorry
it's hard to talk about yourself you
know because it's like
it gets me teary-eyed because I I'm so
I'm filled with so much love and hate
for myself and
you know like I'm constantly battling
like
you know my ability to keep my ego at
Bay and like you know
try to like justify my my [ __ ] up
decisions and justify like my good
decisions you know and like redefine
like what what good is and what evil is
and all this all this stuff
you know
uh I I you know lately it's been really
hard I've been
you know I I know it's hard for
everybody right now but it's like uh
I'm kind of at a standstill I don't
I don't want to go back home
and uh
I want things to work out here you know
I'm not really chasing love like I was
in the past I feel like I've wasted so
much time on that and I just need to
focus on me I don't want to have regrets
I don't want to be famous or anything
and just like want to be happy really
I don't care about money I don't care
about I really don't care about dope
either that much
uh
I just want to find the happiness that I
had at some point in my life where it
felt easy you know
are you bipolar
no I'm not I'm uh
I've been diagnosed my diagnosis is uh
I'm severe severe depression with
psychotic features and I have PTSD and
generalized anxiety
but I think I might be a little ADHD a
little I have social awkwardness
sometimes
uh it's really when I first moved here
I put my whole self out there and I
learned like really quick like
I was vulnerable to the wrong people and
I learned really quick How uh
you know how people could take advantage
of you like being vulnerable
like
you know I still I still kind of like
get caught I catch myself doing that and
saying like way too much information
sometimes or being way too like crazy
like you know
putting myself out there I think it
might scare people because it's just
dared or afraid to be like that raw
sometimes I don't know what are the most
difficult parts of living like this
uh the most difficult parts of living
like this
like living like homeless like and
addicted to drugs
um
jobless
it honestly it's it's like
I don't know just battle it's like the
mental battling of like
justifying yourself constantly and make
yourself feel better and trying to like
grab onto that little bit of Hope and
and like trying to like refill the the
bottle of I deserve this you know I
deserve this I deserve this
is not worth a big part of your
issue here yeah I mean it is for
everybody yeah yeah like
like I know I'm worth it I know I know
that I'm special like
I feel like everybody is everybody has
gotten this chance to like have this
but it's like
it's a lot of people like get a kick out
of like making you question that
constantly like do you deserve it and
saying you don't deserve it you know
because you're you're dirty you don't
take care of yourself you don't go to
the doctor you know you don't
you don't pay your taxes you know yada
like so you don't deserve it like but
what really is the criteria for if you
deserve it or not you know it's just
like
I try to I'm really trying hard really
trying hard to
live each day with with love because I
just want to project love like
constantly and it's been really hard
lately because I've just had a lot of
hate lots of like hate lately Ellie's
like a really hard City like to live in
spiritually like really hard
uh
you know I've met the devil like I or
some kind of entity of the devil many
times in L.A uh I haven't sold my soul
at least I'm pretty sure I have it
um
lots of strange things have happened to
me since I've lived here it's and it's
it's just crazy like I I don't regret
anything like that's happened lots of
scary things you know but I feel like I
needed to be frightened I needed to be
like jilted with that fear or whatever
it is that you know I needed it because
it made you stronger you know
but uh you describe yourself as
self-destructive
um
yeah a little bit
but I like to self-indul I like to
indulge you know
if I wasn't doing so many drugs I'd
definitely be I've had I'd be I'd have a
lot more weight probably it all goes
back to food for me
food was my first addiction
was weight one of the reasons you
started using drugs
um it was more like a body image and
Escape kind of
um
I have mommy and daddy issues you know
from my past and I had my stepdad was
like pretty abusive like psychologically
control freak
so the eating and the OCD and the like
all of that is where it came from I
think my eating disorder evolved into
what my drug addiction is you know now
so
but if I had to like look at it as a
whole picture it's like
not really the eating it's it's all
comes down to like me being able to have
self-control self-discipline
like you know
we're replenishing The Hope thing or
like the self-worth thing like all those
jars
you know
I I wouldn't I would I would rather have
problems than you know it took me to be
squeaky clean egos squeaky clean like
I'd rather have all these problems
in the moment it's like way too much so
it's very overwhelming
there's some positives to this lifestyle
as well like no responsibility no job no
you just can do what you want as you
described earlier yeah and I don't know
I just I feel like everybody should
have a chance to live like that
I'd like to get back into working
I just don't think I can handle it right
now like
I don't think I can handle it right now
well Sentinel addiction kind of gets in
the way of that
yeah
you'd have to get clean from that first
yeah
do you have friends
um yeah I have friends
real friends I don't know I'm not sure I
think some of them if you're not sure
then they're probably not real I I have
major trust issues and um some of them
are fake some of them are will sit there
and listen some of them just want to use
me for drugs and some of them are
vampires I mean I don't know I try to
keep people kind of at arm's distance
because I don't I'm a bad judge of
character I will give somebody benefit
of the doubt like
even I I'll give Hitler a benefit of the
doubt like that's the kind of person I
am
uh which sounds like you know
but
I don't know I'm wearing this thing like
I'm working on you know so
what do you worry about what are you
what are you afraid of now at this point
I'm I'm really afraid of uh
you know I've never like lost somebody
really close to me like this and I'm
afraid of
The Grieving is gonna like
I mean I I almost want to say I'm afraid
of like changing but I know I've already
changed so it's how can I be afraid of
that you know
I guess I'm afraid of like not pulling
it together and disappointing like my
family you know being down here for a
long long time
down here like in California
homeless drug addicted
yeah like I I but I also don't want to
be controlled or
have to feel like guilty because I'm not
living up to other people's expectations
of how they want my life
I don't want to live like that either
and I want to find a happy medium
where I shouldn't have to feel guilty
for certain things you know but I don't
want to burden them and and not make
them proud you know even if it's at like
a
you know whatever level
tell me about your kids
who's raising them right now
um well
I picked I picked families me and Richie
my my ex-boyfriend that passed away
we had picked families for them whenever
I gotten pregnant
the first time it was in
2015 2017.
and I went through the whole pregnancy
almost uh and he was in jail
and um he he wasn't
you know I was sober for the whole
pregnancy too and um I went through the
seventh month totally going I was gonna
I was committed on being a single parent
and I was like gonna do it you know and
I was looking at I had like a grandson
saved up and I was looking at RVs and
you know something just kind of like
struck me and I didn't want that for her
you know I wanted her to grow up like
more like how I grew up you know able to
like do activities and
have means and not grow up in an RV or
have I like the idea of having a a
father figure and a mother figure even
if they're divorced you know like I like
the idea of that being a part of like a
kid's life you know I think what's
important
and I wasn't gonna have that so I chose
I chose the family and um
uh
my daughter Annika she uh is six now
um currently I have lost contact with
her the family
um has dropped completely complete
contact like I haven't received pictures
or anything
um
for some unknown reason I don't know I
the open adoption is was very lenient
like I just wanted to get pictures every
now and then and I'll send her like a
birthday present or something
um my other daughter
um we chose a different family for her
um
and they live in Hollywood Florida and
the mother is a pediatric surgeon
and the father is a retired sheriff or
cop and um they're like great they like
always send pictures they they face time
with my mom
um and they actually want me to be a lot
like more involved so
um
I would like to like work on being more
bombs than that is it hard for you to be
separate from your kids
I think about them a lot but I I'm so
detached
but the minute that I had them
I did to hatch myself you know I didn't
nurse I just completely and I've always
been really good at that like completely
like withdrawing and
uh like of course I'm I would love to
like see them grow up and actually be
present but
I I want I don't want to confuse them
and be too involved right now I believe
I feel like they're the families have it
right to like
you know have their own family and raise
them how they want and you know I feel
like they you know that's what they and
when they're 18 or
my name's out there like I've all
everything's out there for them to ask
questions for them to come meet me you
know
I'm not
I'm still not in a position to be a
parent
and
you know I'm sure that they'll
understand you know
and if they don't they don't but
my Mom was adopted so it's kind of weird
and my mom never like
she she my grandparents were they always
give my mom a guilt trip like if she
asked about her real mom and stuff they
say like the papers are burnt and they
don't have any information and you know
they always made her feel guilty and my
mom never ventured out to try to figure
out who her real mom is
and I'm like my worst fear is that with
my first daughter
who I don't have contact with anymore
and I don't know what the heck's going
on at all my worst fear is that they're
raising her and and saying all these
lies about me or making up some crazy
story about me you know
that's like my worst fear
as a fentanyl addict are you concerned
about
all the people that have died on the
streets
from overdose
yeah I mean yeah of course I've saved
I've saved a lot of people's lives like
just
you know
just being here I never I I'd never even
overdosed on opiates till I came out
here
to LA
um
I wasn't even traditionally uh opiate
addict until I came out here to La I was
a mess and
meth has always been my like go-to like
ecstasy uppers
I
just switched because uh I have issues
with my skin I'm really sensitive to
stuff it's really kind of disgusting and
like gross and I don't like talking
about it but it is what it is
uh I'd like I dream and I I really want
to I can't wait for the day that I'm not
a dope head
I know there's a lot of work to do
what's your biggest regret
shh
oh
[Music]
um
biggest regret
I don't know I don't I don't have any
regrets yet it's really hard to say that
that
it's really hard to say that
because I I hate
I hate that I ever touch drugs you know
they've completely changed my life
but at the same time I don't want to
have regrets
because I still see
the potential for
it to be like the reason that I became
you know like for it to be like part of
the story you know
how do I have any requests
I regret not saying goodbye to my
to Richie before I left and came back
here to LA
you know
I regret I regret that
Glenn what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
um
just
treat everybody equally and with love
and be kind and be humble
all right Quinn thank you so much for
sharing your story
I wish you the best of luck out there
okay